bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
l'événement tant attendu des boules en
france saint quentin en yvelines vit
désormais à l'heure de la ryder cup
l'une des plus prestigieuses
compétitions sportives mondiales tous
les acteurs du territoire s'y prépare de
longue date l'agglomération les
entreprises les commerçants et les saint
quentinois et compris les plus jeunes
alors comment saint quentin en yvelines
vis à ryder cup où vous dit tout ces
parcours
[Musique]
vous
pour la rentrée saint quentin en
yvelines accueille l'un des plus gros
événement sportif de la planète
la ryder cup de golf un événement
particulièrement attendu on est très
très excité et heureux
les saint quentinois sont fiers c'est
une énorme chance pour saint quentin en
yvelines c'est un succès incontestable
la ryder cup de golf sur le sol français
une première durant une semaine les 24
meilleurs joueurs américains et
européens vont s'affronter sur le
parcours de l'albatros du golf national
connu pour être l'un des plus ardues du
monde golfique troisième événement
sportif mondial en termes d'audience
médiatique après la coupe du monde de
football et les jeux olympiques
la ryder cup devra être suivies par 750
millions de téléspectateurs à travers le
monde
[Musique]
et pour accueillir l'événement le site a
considérablement évolué ces derniers
mois il ya des infrastructures
absolument gigantesque qui qui ont
poussé sur le loch national derrière moi
vous avez le plus grand rabbin qui ait
jamais démissionnera de 6800 places au
total
sans oublier les 52 mille mètres carrés
de chapiteaux et les multiples
installations électriques informatiques
et nouveaux points d'eau et y afférents
mais aussi déco et mobilier compris tout
doit être impeccable pour recevoir les
autres prestigieux et notamment les
champions alors les personnes de
prestige il y en a à peu près 60 milles
par jour parce que tout tout le public
et prestigieux pour nous c'est clair on
va 51000 détenteurs de billets pour
chaque jour de match plus les 8000
personnes qui sont invitées dans les
hospitalités par les partenaires
sponsors ou officiel mais ce qui est
important pour nous sur un plan local
régional
c'est le club des partenaires ses
partenaires de grandes entreprises
françaises et notamment
saint-quentinoise ont permis de soutenir
la candidature de golf national à la
manifestation
une aide précieuse pour attirer cet
événement mondial en france
mais effectivement je pense que
savoir si on a quelques stars ou des
célébrités ou oudéa pour femmes
politiques
ben oui oui on aura tiger woods lui même
a été sélectionné pour les politiques le
président emmanuel macron et le premier
ministre edouard philippe
seront présents à la cérémonie
d'ouverture côté match d'exhibition guy
forget dany boon kelly slater ou encore
c'est mieux jackson devrait se prêter au
jeu
on parle aussi de donald trump on n'a
pas fini de tweets et sur les réseaux
sociaux
l'agglomération coup deux autres golf le
golf
isabella à plaisir et le blue green à la
base de loisirs de trappes où nous se
prépare aussi à l'événement on pense que
pendant cette période
on m'a beaucoup parlé de golf déjà donc
ça sera vraiment déjà un plus pour toute
la profession
donc ça nous apportera je dirais déjà
une oeuvre aura un petit peu plus
importante avec une population qui peut
être à la fois locale et étrangère est
aussi une aura un petit peu plus
importante au niveau des nouveaux
golfeurs du coup le blue green organise
des journées portes ouvertes jusqu'au 21
octobre
ici deux parcours 18 trous et un
parcours si tout compact destiné aux
débutants car la cible recherchée et
bien les néophytes
pour l'agglomération aussi la ryder cup
est une chance rayonnement international
retombées économiques
l'agglomération s'y prépare depuis
longtemps et a entraîné avec elle les
plus jeunes saint quentinois
[Musique]
c'est un événement hors normes dans
l'histoire de saint quentin auxquels se
rajoutent bien sur le fait que certains
au site est choisi pour les jeux
olympiques avec quatre sites les
pigments tout cela bien sûr
et assez renforce cette image de haute
performance économique de saint quentin
on est dans la haute valeur ajoutée
aussi bien économiques que sportives
c'est un moment de rencontre aussi entre
acteurs économiques
rien qu'un et puis européen on sait que
la médiatisation est très forte
c'est un milliard trois cents millions
de personnes qui vont regarder sa part
dernier line bien sûr il ya une
mobilisation de tout le monde ça
commence dans les écoles de golf est
devenu beaucoup plus connus intéresser
beaucoup de plus de stages avec les
enfants ça mobilise tout le monde
à 50 ans on nous à l'agglomération qui
messieurs en première ligne pour
organiser tous nos agents tous nos tous
nos étudiants toutes les entreprises
également qui participe depuis dix ans
l'agglomération multiplie les
initiatives pour rendre le golf
accessible à tous en 2015 le territoire
s'est associé à la fédération française
de golf et à la direction des services
départementaux de l'éducation nationale
des yvelines
le projet le carnet de golf celui ci a
permis à près de 1700 élèves saint
quentinois de s'initier au golf en 2017
de territoire mettait en place le
village ryder cup dans chacune des 12
communes de l'agglomération
ceci afin de proposer des animations
golfique gratuite au coeur des villes
autre partenariat celui avec
l'association municipale as les golfs
créée en 2002 pour lutter contre
l'exclusion des enfants en difficulté
tous les ans ici sur ce sur ce practice
on prend une douzaine d'enfants de la
cinquième à la troisième une douzaine de
collégiens qui sont en grande difficulté
scolaire l'avantagent 2
de ça c'est que on prend les enfants une
heure par semaine et surtout celle
remotive et on a un taux de réussite
énorme
ces collégiens ils ont ils ont deux
tuteurs ils ont un tuteur sportif qui
est nous et twitter professionnels au
cours de cette donc le tuteur sportif il
est là pour les valoriser pour leur
montrer qu'il ya des adultes qui font
confiance en eux et rien que cette
confiance on les voit évoluer
donc ça c'est ma grande fierté
[Musique]
le goal de véhiculer des valeurs parce
que il ya le respect le respect d'autrui
le respect du terrain et puis surtout la
concentration est il respecté les
cheveux blancs ça c'est important
outre ces collégiens le club possède
deux cent soixante d'adhérents
passionnés de golf
la snb golf échanges avec les écoles sur
le golfe afin de montrer que le sport
est accessible à tous et fait ainsi des
émules chaque année c'est près de 600
enfants de cm1 cm2 des douze communes de
l'agglomération qui découvrent ce sport
cette année 180 d'entre eux ont assisté
à l'open de france grâce à la smb 2 sang
et or ont assisté à la ryder cup
accompagnés des bénévoles de
l'association
[Musique]
nous l'avons vu les entreprises on joue
un rôle important dans l'obtention de la
compétition en france et sur le site du
golf national
les hôteliers et les commerçants se
préparent également à l'événement et
pour certains les retombées économiques
se font déjà sentir
air france bmw lacoste mais aussi le
nôtre et bouygues construction deux
entreprises du territoire ont soutenu la
candidature du golf national à la ryder
cup à travers le club des partenaires
france 2018
[Musique]
les commerçants s'investissent également
en vue de l'événement
bienvenue à l'hôtel mercure de maurepas
l'établissement s'est mise à l'heure de
la ryder cup le practice est à la
disposition de la clientèle durant tout
l'événement
histoire de voir si un golfeur sommeille
en chacun de nous c'est une opportunité
extraordinaire pour la région et pour
tout dire on n'a aucune expérience en la
matière c'est la première fois que ça se
produit donc sens en recul on
s'attendait à un volume d'activité
important sur le sur cette période
principe d'une semaine et on se rend
compte que la demande dépasse nos
espérances
et pour l'occasion l'hôtel mercure à
réaliser des animations spécifiques
il ya d'abord des mises en place qui
sont qui sont faites en collaboration
avec les organisateurs de la ryder cup
vous allez avoir par exemple une navette
spécifique qui va venir à plusieurs fois
par jour pour prendre des gens qui sont
hébergés chez nous et les transporter
sur leurs lieux sur les lieux de la
compétition
nous avons aussi un bureau qui est mise
à disposition d'un représentant la
riderz cup sur le sur l'autel en interne
outre le practice de l'accueil les
tables du restaurant présenteront une
décoration tout golfique et puis
évidemment
l'hôtel a été mis sur son 31 tous nous
avons tout réviser de manière à ce qu'il
n'y ait aucun couac pendant la période
de la compétition
[Musique]
aucun couac non plus du côté des
restaurateurs
ici on vit au rythme des multiples
manifestations sportives qui ont lieu
dans l'agglomération et on maîtrise un
peu comme à chaque fois dès qu'un
événement sportif
on essaye d'y réfléchir et de savoir ce
que veulent les clients
ces deux cent mille personnes qui vont
cette année sur la ville l'avantagent
pour nous c'est que les navettes partent
de la gare
et puis bah le soir je pense que oui il
y aura du monde entraîneur la ville donc
là on change pas réellement nos
habitudes on va se mettre un peu plus en
place comme qu'on a le paris brest ou
avec du monde une question se pose
pourtant au sein de l'établissement
face à l'affluence du à la ryder cup le
bistrot du théâtre gratuit ouvrir ses
portes le dimanche
l'autre question c'est là près ryder cup
qu'en sera-t-il de retombées de la
compétition l'après ryder cup s'annonce
très bien ça veut dire que les gens vont
vouloir venir visiter et c'est là la
presse est la clé de la réussite c'est
les retombées économiques pour le pays
en termes de tourisme
les gens vont vouloir venir comme une
espèce de pèlerinage
au golf national pendant des années à
venir et surtout s'il ya de l'émotion
s'il ya des larmes
et s'il y a quelques images iconiques de
ce golf et la ryder cup
on aura un petit peu plus de golfeurs
parce que c'est vrai qu'on a toujours
des a priori par rapport au monde du
golf on dit c'est pas pour nous mais la
légende en l'entendant parler et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on aura un
engouement comme on l'a pu le vivre pour
le tennis on le vivra aujourd'hui pour
le golf mais on va montrer aux gens que
le golf c'est pas c'est pas juste
réservé à une certaine élite le golf
c'est des émotions le golf est un sport
de toute une vie le golf c'est pour les
enfants de 5 ans aux grands parents
jusqu'à 90 ans ça vous apprend également
beaucoup de choses de golf le méditer
l'adresse l'étiquette
voilà donc c'est tout ça qu'on veut
passer comme message en accueillant la
ryder cup c'est dé diaboliser le golfe
je pense que cet événement va avoir
comme tous les grands événements
sportifs va nous permettre
comment dire de faire porter un regard
différent sur saint quentin en yvelines
qui est moins connu que la défense mais
qui est un pôle d'affaires très
important et qui va permettre aussi de
mettre en avant certains nombres de
d'offre touristique de loisirs avec les
forêts a avec le tout les les
infrastructures dont on dispose sont ils
méritent d'être connues d'autant qu'un
autre évènement majeur se prépare déjà
les jeux olympiques de 2024
quatre sites de l'agglomération ont été
retenues pour diverses compétitions
pour nous la ryder cup c'est une
répétition aussi pour les jeux
olympiques et une sauce que l'épreuve de
transport de sécurité de l'organisation
de restauration de tout ça on va on va
avoir la même chose x par quatre donc
c'est pour nous aussi en même temps une
très bonne répétition de haut niveau je
pense que la ville s'y prépare déjà au
géo 1
on est en train de reconstruire des
hôtels un peu partout donc oui mais
depuis des restaurants donc oui ce sera
ce sera un test nous avons pour projet
de construire un hôtel voyez on y pense
déjà
c'est 2024 ça va venir très vite et nous
sommes en plein dans l'avant projet
bon
vous savez tous désormais sur l'avant
pendant et après haider cup très belle
compétition à toutes et à tous zhao
[Musique]